chase why under lives change
organizations organization change the
world
all right good afternoon thank you for
having me here today
so I want to ask you a question have you
ever had one of those holiday meals with
your family that starts off all pleasant
but then suddenly it ruptures into this
angry contentious battle over politics
isn't it so sad and yet so common for
this to happen I have a similar story
and it's when I was growing up we had
some family friends that were pretty
much like family to me we would have
every family meal or every holiday meal
together and in fact we would eat
together almost once a week we would go
to their house all the time to watch
these high tech movies on their big
projector screen and their laserdisc
technology but something's come over
nuts something has happened between us
over the years
there's been a wedge it's been placed
between in our relationship and that
wedge is politics it's gotten to the
point now in politics where we have a
hard time trusting each other because of
the battles that we've had over politics
we've labeled each other as you know the
other opposing group Republicans or
Democrats and therefore we find out hard
to just believe what the other one's
saying so for example our friends will
look at us and if we say something that
they don't agree with they'll say well
what do you know you're from California
now of course you're such a liberal and
so I've noticed that this has had an
impact on me and it's not just by
tearing apart a relationship but it's
also because I found myself choosing to
talk to people about politics with only
people that agree with me I didn't want
to go into those battles I didn't want
to have these discussions and
disagreements and confrontations
I'm much preferred to talk with people
that agreed with me and then I could
label the Republicans as a Republican
and it made me feel much better
but then I came to Stanford the place of
enlightenment differing opinions and
open minds what I found myself doing was
talking to people with different opinion
and if you could believe it or not I
found myself learning so much from these
people I will live in on some issues
like fiscal policy issues I found myself
moving my position a little bit more to
the center from the liberal extreme that
I had before on social issues I didn't
exactly move my position but I was able
to understand where these people were
coming from and that really gave me an
appreciation for their opinions and I
really learned that it's such a shame
how can I learn if I only choose to talk
to people that agree with me and so
that's why I'm here today
I want to persuade you all to find
people that disagree with you in
politics and take time to understand
where they're coming from I mean it
makes sense because we all come from
different backgrounds and different
experiences so it's only inevitable
we're gonna have different opinions and
different beliefs so when I started this
presentation I want to started putting
together this presentation I was
thinking what was it that that made me
want to only talk to people that I
agreed with so through my experiences
and through some research I found that
what happens is when there's two people
that disagree with each other we tend to
label each other as opponents and
opponents is already a negative
connotation so once you have an opponent
it's really easy to stereotype these
people and kind of create some demonic
characters for these people well once
you get to that level if you start
discussing something that you different
opinions in it's very easy to end up in
battles and anger and because of all of
that negative sentiment it's just it's
just much easier just to avoid the
confrontation and not talk about
politics with people that you disagree
with it turns out that I'm also not
alone with this feeling that I should
only talk to people that agree with me
research also shows that on a scale of
choosing people and friends and family
that mostly disagree with you from
choosing friends and family that mostly
agree with you the average American will
choose people
they generally agree with on politics
also when there's groups of people that
generally agree with each other
statistics have shown that 79 percent of
them are likely to talk about politics
but if there's groups of people that
disagree on politics and only 29 percent
of them will actually talk about
politics so the problem with this is
then we're creating these silos of
opinions and then the silo these
opinions end up becoming a little bit
more extreme than they should be
other studies have shown that when
people with different perspectives come
together they end up forming the
consensus but when there's groups of
people that are like-minded made up of
like-minded individuals they will tend
to form a consensus that is much more
extreme so this imprint of a story from
when I was in elementary school my
favorite band was New Kids on the Block
yeah the problem is I had never heard a
New Kids on the Block song before my
life so that was purely a decision of
consensus and not an informed decision
so where does that bring us here today
well basically if we want to be the most
informed as we can be on the issues then
we need to talk more with people that we
disagree with if we can talk more with
people that we disagree with maybe we
can move this average arrow more towards
the neutral center where people
generally just naturally choose to talk
to people they agree with and disagree
with if we can talk to people on both
sides of the or if we can understand
both sides of the stories then we will
become more understanding will
stereotype less and we will be more
informed if we understand both sides of
the story then we will learn to
appreciate differing opinions and by
talking more we can actually understand
each other and empathize more with each
other and build relationships better
and then in the end we don't have to be
so scared to talk about politics we
don't have to worry about politics
coming in between our relationships so I
challenge you all to go find some
friends and family at least half of
which you disagree with in politics go
take them out to coffee or get a lunch
with them and find out what it is that
they believe don't just hear what they
have to say but truly listen and truly
understand why why it is that they
believe what they believe not only will
you learn from this but I strongly
believe that you will also find out that
you have more in common than you thought
so go challenge yourself to become more
informed politically thank you very much
you